hey guys this is Dennis the founder
thank you and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
rules human what episode is it's called
arrhythmia okay so last week I had said
that I actually had liked that episodic
episode because I was interested in what
the story was this week on my hand I
wasn't quite as interested how about you
yeah I mean it was it's fine I get I
think the show is a good show that could
be a great show but I think it's just it
really is is getting stuck in kind of
the crime of the week and that's not
it's it's a nice-looking show disguised
as a cop procedural and that's okay
because nothing wrong with cops
so the procedurals but it's like I just
I want something that this show could be
so much more unique like I know it's
there it has the actors it has it has
the world they just need to build on it
not give us a case about a case of the
week this whole case I also think that
it's with doing an episodic thing with a
procedural you run to the trap of being
hit or miss yeah where it's like okay
like last week I like last week's
episode even though is episode like
episodic one okay but then this week I
did you know where if you have a bigger
storyline and everyone's invested you
know if you're doing it right then every
episode will be a hit right and then
everybody's saying you know who we're
talking to they get still early it's
like well I'm as far as I know looking
ahead I mean we're on Episode six then
you only have nine announce they have
Fox's not said oh we're gonna give this
13 we're gonna give it 16 or 22 we just
feed nine episodes so it's definitely
not gonna do tour no let's say it does
10 or 13 if it even goes I mean they got
a there they're halfway there we're
probably it's got to get somewhere at
some point we haven't even touched on
any of the topics from season from
episode one yet from the premiere I
think they're trying to follow kind of
that fringe formula where they're you
know they're doing these episodic stuff
with like but they're not even showing
hints though of this larger so the
insyndicate and his girlfriend and
whatnot I think that's my main concern
is they should be at least dropping
little little foreshadowing of future
events
I mean I guess to go over some good
things I mean you know the the Dorian
you know the little ride along they'd
yes you know there's nice there's always
good moments between Karl Urban and
Michael Ealy they're doing a great job
with you know playing off of each other
like that's fine that part of this show
was great I just want you know it's the
build a bigger story yeah and then
bringing in the other identical models
Dorian you know it was funny like
pulling out his eye and accidentally
drop it guy making the wrong arrest
because his files weren't updated
because you know the guy thought he was
a you know doing a robbery or something
so I mean yeah it's there's good moments
yes yeah there's definitely good moments
especially between John Kennedy and
Dorian and in this episode his like not
as clone but is you know is identical
model so but the actual storyline of the
the fake heart not the fake hearts but
the synthetic hearts yeah I didn't
really care much for I mean it's we've
seen this before I mean they're selling
synthetic you know synthetic you know
organs on the black market but it like
this is nothing new yeah you know I
think this is the problem
yeah it's just they need to again it's
like sci-fi is that such a good job now
star Galactica you talk about politics
race religion all these interesting
topics like I know they can go there
with this show they just haven't you
know they've got two very they're
playing it very safe I think that's what
this is the show seems like a very safe
show they're not taking any chances yeah
yeah I just hope they decide after this
mint because this was this a midseason
fell it's not really midseason because
there's nine episodes but they're taking
a three week break yeah so this is kind
of like a in a sense so I hope when they
come back that the they do start getting
into the bigger storyline yeah the I
guess for me that the whole heart attack
thing I just never connected with the
characters oh and I didn't really you
know I know they're you know some
people's lives were in danger but but
because we don't really know them it was
harder to care about that way so much
technology was cool a little like what
Minka Kelly was doing with a little like
you know voice you know translator thing
the woman was you know speaking and he
could hear she could hear her and then
she would speak back and they keep you
in their native
which I mean that was it's nice to see
some of the technology but again it's
just nothing sci-fi has been a lot of
sci-fi so you really got to do something
unique and interesting to kind of
separate yourself from everybody else
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the episode you can post your
comments below on the website and
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
hero pro make sure to subscribe to that
already come check us out on Twitter I
was like the dentist myself about almost
human if you're liking this episodic
formula cop procedural or do you want to
see a bigger story you comes out this
pink hero I'm at Griffin de and we have
some of a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and just help us
out by sharing our videos on Twitter or
Facebook or any other social networking
[Music]